TIMOTHY JORDAN: All right
so this is our talk
today, Surf the Stream.
We're going to be talking
about Google Buzz, location
and social gaming.
If that's what you're here for
you're in the right room.
If that's not what you're here
for you're in the wrong room,
which is sad because this
is going to be really fun.
If you'd like to take a look at
the live notes being taken
about the session on Wave you
can go to the following
bit.ly link, it's
bit.ly/buzzbingowave.
Also there's a moderator gadget
on there, so you can start
inputting questions there.
Also you'll be able to ask
questions live on these
microphones near the
end of the session.
The hashtag for this
session is #buzzbingo.
And there's a URL for the
application we built
for this session.
It's buzz-bingo.appspot.com.
Feel free to go there now
and check it out or you
can check it out later.
I'm Timothy Jordan, I'm
a developer advocate
working at Google.
BOB AMAN: And I'm Bob Aman.
I'm a developer programs
engineer, also at Google.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: We're here
today because one of our
primary tasks is to work with
the developer community
building on Google's platforms.
And today we're going to
be talking about the
Google Buzz API.
If you want to find us online
you can use our Buzzes or our
Twitters, which are
up there as well.
All right, so today we're going
to talk a little bit about the
conversational web
and Google Buzz.
Then we're going to go in and
look at some apps and demos
that have been build on the
Buzz API or are in process.
We're going to look at
something that ShareThis
has been working on.
We're going to look at Boxees
integration with Buzz and
we're going to look at the
game we built for this
session, Buzz Bingo.
Afterwards, we're going to talk
a little bit about growing the
Google Buzz ecosystem and at
the end we're going to take
some questions and hopefully
provide some really
excellent answers.
All right, so first off,
the conversation web.
As you've probably heard from a
lot of sessions here at Google
I/O from Chris Chabot, Chris
Messina, Joseph Smarr, John
Panzer and Will Norris.
they've all been talking a
lot about the conversation
web and Google Buzz.
And the conversational
web is all about good
internet conversations.
And there's just a few required
elements that we see in a nice
conversational web apparatus.
First is the ability to post
messages to the internet.
And to be able to include rich
media and links to other places
on the internet in that post.
The ability for people to
respond to that post and
mention their friends to bring
them into the conversation and
this is what we consider
the conversational web.
This ability to have
conversations online as
if it were in real life.
And our entry into this space
is in fact Google Buzz.
As you can see from this post
by DeWitt Clinton, who linked
to an article about the Droid
Incredible-- you may have heard
of this phone-- he posted
about this article and people
joined that conversation.
You'll see there's mentions in
line in that conversation and
people are being brought
into that conversation.
People are linking to this,
there's rich media, it's
really a great way for
people to connect online
and that's Google Buzz.
All right, so people
are building on top
of this platform.
Google Buzz is more than
just the product that's
embedded in Gmail.
Now you're able to build
applications that work with
Google Buzz outside of Gmail.
ShareThis has been
working on something.
They if you know them are a
sharing network reaching
400 million consumers
across 800,000 sites.
Their core belief is simple
sharing across channels and
aggregated curation of what's
being shared on the web.
With the rise of social
plug-ins, widgets of every type
and flavor it was important to
the ShareThis developer team to
create a social widget that
aggregates top shared content
and social comments form
across Google Buzz and other
networks and services.
And that's what their
stream widget does.
ShareThis expects the social
stream widget to be available
to embed on publishers sites
in June and they have a beta
list open on their site now.
So you can go and check it out
and try and get involved.
We're excited to see ShareThis
building on its very cool
widget and can't wait to see
what they'll come up with next.
As you can see from the mocks
here it's a really interesting
way to take conversations
happening elsewhere on the
internet and embed
them in any site.
Another application that I'd
like to highlight is Boxee.
Boxees's been working with us
to help test the API and
yesterday they introduced some
exciting new applications.
Boxee users will be able to
share what they're watching
with friends on Google Buzz and
to import their Buzz feed into
Boxee to watch video
from their friends.
And now you can see video
recommendations from friends
on Google, Buzz, Twitter,
Facebook and Boxee itself.
As they say over at Boxee it's
like being able to channel
surf through water-cooler
conversation from your coach.
Let's take a quick look.
On the Boxee home screen you'll
be able to see a list of items
from Google Buzz in your
feed on the left there.
You click on one that looks
interesting and then it shows
you the Buzz comment and
links you to the video.
You hit play and you start
watching that video right away,
shared to you from Google Buzz.
Once you've decided you want to
share something all you have to
do is in the upper right-hand
corner hit that heart
icon to share.
Enter custom text ot just
tell your followers you love
it and send them a link.
We think this type of shared
recommendation is going to
be really cool and you can
check it out now on Boxee.
All right and this is the
third demo that we wanted
to show you today.
This is what we built for
this session and it's
called Buzz Bingo.
Essentially this game is
Buzz Bingo as you've see
at conferences before.
You get a Bingo board and it's
filled with keywords and you
mark them off and
you get a Bingo.
But in this case you're playing
Buzz Bingo through Google Buzz.
So by joining conversations
you're marking off
keywords on that board.
So I'm just going to take you
quickly through an overview
here and then we'll look at
some screenshots and
we'll do a demo.
So first off you would
sign-in and auth for Buzz.
It'll then generate
a board for you.
You join conversations, it'll
mark the board with the
keywords in those conversations
that you've joined and
eventually you get Bingo.
Let's start with signing-in
and authing for Buzz.
Pretty much you land on this
page, buzz-bingo.appspot.com.
You sign-in to the game and
for this Cammy Crepe our
lovely test user, will be
signing-in to the game.
And we get brought to an
authorization screen.
It tells you or any user what
this application will be
allowed to do with your data.
Hit OK, grant the access and
then you've authed four of us.
The game will then generate a
board for you and you'll notice
all the boards that it
generates are with keywords
from Google IO sessions
here today and yesterday.
You then go out and join
conversations on Buzz.
So in this case we see Tina
Tamarind has mentioned that
she's really excited to
come see this session.
And she mentions social
web in her comment.
Cammy Crepe then makes a
comment on Tina's
post mentioning
buzzbingo.io@gmail.com and
we've joined that conversation.
The game will then find that
mention, look for keywords,
and mark it off on
the Buzz Bingo Board.
And eventually you get 5 in
a row and there's a Bingo.
So it's a pretty
simple concept.
What we think is a really fun
game built on Buzz and it uses
the Buzz APIs built
with App Engine.
So let me do a quick demo here.
Essentially I'm just going
to switch over to Cammy's
Buzz Bingo Board here.
As you can see I've started
a new game and I have
App Engine marked off.
I'm going to go over to this
other tab, this really
interesting article about our
new WebM video fomat and I'm
going to Buzz about it.
And I include the link.
I'll even put an image,
how about that?
And I'm going to mention
buzzbingo.io@gmail.com.
Post this Buzz and it's
as simple as that.
In a moment I'll go back over
to the board and you'll
see that HTML5 will be
marked off on that.
It's just as simple as that.
Being able to join
conversations on Buzz as part
of a game was something that
we found was really,
really interesting.
This idea of social gaining,
but occurring in a
conversational web format.
All I have to do is make this
post and the App Engine game
will go out on the internet
and find that Buzz post
using the Buzz API.
Find that keyword in that post
and mark it off on the board.
Let me switch back over
to the board here and
there we have it.
The HTML5 square has
been marked off.
Yay, the demo worked.
Let me switch to
the slides here.
All right, now I'm going to
turn it over to Bob who will go
a little bit more in depth with
how this works technically.
BOB AMAN: All right, so I'm
going to be showing a lot
of the code that we
used to build this.
It's all written in Python
and it runs on App Engine.
This is the architecture
diagram of how it's all set up.
Your user is going to interact
through the-- is my mic
working?-- through the Buzz UI
and they're also going to
interact through the Buzz
Bingo game on App Engine.
And the game will also
communicate with the Buzz API,
which in turn also talks to us.
So I'm going to walk through
the flow that we were
talking about earlier.
Starting with signing-in
and authing for buzz.
So this is the code that you
use to build your client
and authorize it.
So the first thing you
have to do is set up
your oauth consumer.
You have to obatin a oauth
consumer key in secret.
You can do that from a
page on the accounts API.
You have to register your
domain and it gives
you the secret back.
And you need to
specify a scope.
We're using a full access
scope here, but there's
also a read-only scope
that you can use.
So the first step after you
have setup your consumer is
to obtain the request token.
The request token, you need
to specify a callback, but
otherwise that's the only
parameter that you need.
And you generate an
authorization URL using
that request token.
You do need to first save
the request token to
the datastore though.
Then you redirect the user to
the authorization URL that was
built and that looks like this.
And the user, once they click
through this page they will be
redirected back to the callback
that you gave them and that
callback will have a parameter
called the oauth verifier.
You look up the request token
in the data store and pass that
back to the client and then you
have your access token which
you fetch from the accounts API
using the verifier that it
gave you in the callback.
And then you've upgraded your
request token to an access
token and you can save
that to the datastore.
Now you have full
access to the API.
Once have access to the API we
proceed to generate the board.
The way that we do that is
actually pretty simple.
We have a predefined
topic list, which we've
stored in a constant.
We just choose 24 of the topics
at random just iterating
through the list picking 1 of
the topics until we
finally have a list
containing 24 items.
And then we go and we
actually generate the
scores in the board.
We don't care about the
free space in the center.
There's no topic for that so if
x and y are 2 we skip over it
and we commit the square
to the datastore.
We name the key based on the x
and y location so that it is
fast to do the lookup for it.
We give each square the topic
that's associated with it.
And then for the convenience of
accessing it we then inserted
into a two-dimensinal array
inside our player
data structure.
So then the user goes out and
they join conversations.
And while they're out joining
conversations the App
Engine game is pulling the
consumption feed for the
buzzbingo.io@gmail.com user.
So it tries to mark off your
board as these tasks are run.
So the first thing that happens
when we go to scan a new post
is we take the comment text and
the post text and we search
through our predefined list of
topics and we basically pull
out all of the comment or all
of the keywords that appear in
that topic list and we save
that in the topics found array.
And then we take the list of
topics that the player actually
has that appear on their
board and we calculate the
intersection between the two.
Because you're only going to
score topics that are on your
board and appeared in the
comment that we care about.
And we're actually scoring
multiple players at the same
so that's why we have to
do this intersection here.
And then we pick one of the
topics at random from the
intersection and score
the post on that topic.
And when you go to score a post
you can only do that once per
player and it enforces that.
When you go to score the
player-- or sorry, score the
post-- it then goes and
tries to award badges.
And we have a whole bunch of
conditions that we check to
figure out which badge we
should award at any given time.
So for example, with the share
and share alike badge that
Timothy demonstrated earlier
when he shared an article we
checked the post
for attachments.
And if we find an attachment
of type article then we award
the player the share badge.
If we have a geocode on the
post and the author of the post
wasn't the player then we know
that they've joined a
conversation with a geocode
metadata on it and we
award them the geo badge.
But if on the other hand, it
was the player then we award
them the mobile badge for
posting a relevant comment
from their mobile phone.
And when we give out a badge we
want to send a message to the
player telling them, hey we've
awarded you a badge, so we
start to assemble a message
that we transmit back
to the Buzz API.
And so the first thing we do is
we create a badge attachment
containing the icon of the
badge we're awarding and we
assign that a type of photo.
But we also want to advertise
the game so we attach a link
attachment to the game itself
so that you can easily
navigate back to the game.
And we assign that a type
of article, a title, and
the appropriate URI.
And then we go to actually
construct the post itself.
We give it some post content,
we give it the two attachments
that we assembled just prior
and we decided that we wanted
to geocode all of the
posts to Mosconi.
So we have a venue geocode
and place ID that we attach
to the post as well.
And then finally we just simply
call a client, create post with
the post data structure
that we've built.
And then finally when we want
to go determine that you've
made a Bingo we use
this algorithm.
It's pretty simple.
We have initialized two arrays,
which basically are the counts
of all of the marked posts in
each row and column and then we
just iterate over the board and
increment each of
those counters.
And if any of the counters
reach 5 then you've
achieved a Bingo.
The interesting thing that we
did here to make it really
simple is we add the two ones
in the center there and that's
just for the free space.
Then we award you the Bingo
badge if you have 5 of them.
In order to keep track of the
leader board we also increment
a Bingo count so that you can
see who has the most Bingos
in the game so far.
The source code for Buzz
Bingo is open source.
So if you want to take a look
at what we've done you can go
to that URL and take
a look around.
There's some really
interesting stuff in there.
I sort of glossed over a lot
because it's just way out of
scope, but it goes into a
lot of depth in the source.
And you can play
around with that.
You can run it on your own App
Engine instance if you like.
The Google Buzz
API is live now.
The documentation is here
and I'm going to turn it
back over to Timothy.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All right, so
one the reasons Bob and I
wanted to do this is that we
thought it would be fun to
write something that
was innovative.
Something that you wouldn't
expect to be built on
the Buzz platform.
You wouldn't necessarily expect
to be playing a social game on
a conversational web product,
but I think we've demonstrated
that not only can you build it,
but it's actually kind of cool.
And I hope that you do all have
a chance to go out to
buzz-bingo@appspot.com and play
with this and also to take a
look at the open source project
to see how it's built.
At Google it's important for us
to make it easy for people to
build on top of our products
and even more importantly to
use open standards to do that.
In the Buzz API we're using
activity streams, we're using
oauth, we're PubSubHubBub
and we're using Salmon.
And these are open protocols,
they're opened standards that
are being used acrossed
the web today.
And they're also what the
Buzz API is built upon.
That makes it easy for
something like this, this
is the topology of the
game as it is today.
This is what it actually looks
a little bit more like with the
activity streams and Salmon and
oauth and PubSubHubBub being
the glue, being what holds
the Buzz API together.
It can then become
something more like this.
Is that although this game was
built with Buzz in mind, by the
user interacting with the App
Engine app or interacting with
the Buzz product itself.
One day we're hoping that a
product like this could also be
built for Buzz, it could be
built for Cliqset, it could be
built for Blogger, it could
be built for StatusNet.
Because they're all using
the same protocols.
We feel pretty strongly that
these protocols are a really
great choice and we're
excited that the API
is built upon them.
And with that I'm hoping that
before we get to answer some
questions that you're all
feeling pretty inspired to go
out there and build your own
products on the Buzz API.
We've got some really
great resources out
there to help you.
There are the docs on the code
site, which I believe is
code.google.com/API/buzz/docs
and from there you can also
find the developer forum
that's really, really useful.
So I'd like to open it up
for questions and answers.
You can go to the wave
bit.ly/buzzbingowave and type
in your questions in the
moderator there or you can step
up to one of these microphones
in the center of the room and
ask your question live.
AUDIENCE: So this is just a
general question about Buzz.
It seems like it has a lot of
similar feature sets to Wave
and when I first saw it pop up
I thought, oh, they must of
implemented Wave in Gmail now
and they're calling it
Buzz, so why are they
2 separate products?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: You know,
that's a question that I've
heard a couple times and I
can tell you my personal
opinion on the differences
between Wave and Buzz.
I typically use Wave as a
living document product.
If I want to have a
conversation with somebody, I
want that to last a long time
and I'd like that to eventually
have that become kind of a
document that's a great
use case for Wave.
Whereas, Buzz is more like
your daily conversations
or idea sharing.
And I think the feature sets
involved in both products
really sort of support those
2 different use cases.
All right, I'm going to turn to
the moderator gadget unless
anybody else wants to
step to a microphone.
It's lots of fun.
Oh, we got another
live question.
AUDIENCE: Kind of piggy backing
off of that last question, are
we going to see more real time
in that daily conversational
activity stream that Buzz is?
Well, using some
elements from Wave.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I'm not
sure if I understand
the question correctly.
You're asking, is there
going to be more real
time interaction on Buzz?
AUDIENCE: Well, yeah, one of
the features we see with Wave
is you know, active in context
conversations, right?
So you can see the cursor,
for example, moving.
That's not Buzz in a way, is
that done purposefully or
is there going to be more
of this live in context
conversations within Buzz?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Well I know in
the Buzz product today if you
were commenting on a post and
somebody else were to comment
on a post that would show up
in real time in the page.
Is that the kind of thing
you're talking about?
Yeah, so I think some of
those features are already
build in, but you know--
BOB AMAN: Yeah we support
PubSubHubBub as already built
in and that's actually
already live and works.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Are you
familiar with PubSubHubBub?
AUDIENCE: Yep, yep.
BOB AMAN: Yeah, it works.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's
totally in there and
it works swimmingly.
Let's see if there are
questions up here.
Well, so this first question,
is there any plan to integrate
Google linked Buzz services
such as reader so that when
sharing an item in reader the
users who both get the Buzz and
subscribe to the reader feed
only get the Buzz or read it in
reader only and not
see it in Buzz?
So this seems like a
de-duplication across
multiple services question.
BOB AMAN: We are exposing ids
that we can use to de-dupe.
And we already have a lot
of code in there for
doing de-duping.
But I honestly didn't quite
understand the question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
BOB AMAN: That would be
awesome, please clarify.
AUDIENCE: You're basically
right on the money.
It's a duplication, right.
So I have my friend over
there, he gets both my Reader
feed and Buzz from me.
He sees it in both.
We go into reader we have
to mark it as read in
Reader as seen in Buzz.
and basically it seems like
kind of backwards from sharing.
We want to mark it as read in
Reader automatically if he saw
it in Buzz and vice versa.
BOB AMAN: OK, so we are
planning on supporting the Atom
cross-posting extension and
we're basically going to, at
any time a feed comes into Buzz
the id of that feed will then
get exposed on the way back out
in the Atom cross-posting
extension so that any other
services that are consuming
those feeds and looking at them
can do intelligent
things with that.
And so it should be perfectly
possible to do that.
00:27:51,594 --> 00:27:51,558
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Next question
here, how is a user supposed
to interact with both
Buzz and Wave together?
I just see Wave as
an improved Buzz.
I think that's sort of
similar to the question--
BOB AMAN: Yeah, the
previous question.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I think there
are really 2 different products
with 2 different use cases.
Will Android users anytime soon
be able to upload captured
videos to their Buzz?
I don't know, but that
sounds really cool.
BOB AMAN: It certainly does.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Right now you
can upload to YouTube and you
can share YouTube videos
directly in a Buzz
by linking to them.
And that works very, very well.
BOB AMAN: And you can also do
that through the API with the
client library that I showed.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Are there
any plans to-- oh,
that's the same one.
Are there any plans to link
Google Buzz with Facebook
as has already been done
with Twitter and YouTube?
I have no idea.
BOB AMAN: It's a good question.
Perhaps address it to
press@google.com.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah, they
would be good ones to ask.
The integration of Buzz into
Latitude has been very
successful, are there
any plans to introduce
a check-in feature?
I think that's a
really cool idea.
I don't know if we've done
anything along those
lines or not, but I'll
mention it to the team.
Do we have any other
questions live from the
audience in studio?
No questions.
Do we have anything else
to say about the API?
We've got a few minutes left.
BOB AMAN: We have 3 client
libraries available.
All of them make it
really easy to develop
against the Buzz API.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: We
have a Python one.
BOB AMAN: Python, PHP and Java.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And then I'm
also going to be working on an
action script one that should
come out in a few weeks or so.
BOB AMAN: And there's a CSharp
library in progress as well.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So if writing
the code from scratch isn't
your thing there are libraries
available that makes
this quite a bit easier.
In fact, for the App Engine
game Bob used the Python
library to do it, which I
understand made it lots easier.
Let me just bring up some
of those code pages.
All right, so this is the
documentation and it's
written very well.
I think you guys will really
enjoy it, so I encourage
you to visit this website.
BOB AMAN: Yeah, it would help
if it was on the right screen.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: There we are.
I encourage you to visit
this website and check
out the API online.
Look at this documentation.
Take a look at the libraries
available for working with the
Buzz API and think up something
really cool to do
and go for it.
If you have any trouble get
in touch, we'd love to help.
And with that I
think we're good.
If you'd like to come up and
ask us any more questions
off mic you're more
than welcome to.
BOB AMAN: Thank you.